most of preventing russia further
escalation will always be
lower than the cost of stopping it and
mitigating its consequences
and i hope our friends and partners
understand that
it is way more effective to clearly make
moscow understand
that a new stage of aggression will have
dire consequences for russia
international isolation and painful
economic sanctions
well what can we realistically expect
from the west especially from the u.s
now that joe biden is president
let's bring in jonathan katz from the
german marshall fund he joins me tonight
from washington it's good to see you
again jonathan
um what does washington make of the
buildup of russian troops
near the border with ukraine
well i think there's a there's deep
concern in washington about the buildup
it's not only
uh on the donbas but it's also in the
black sea sea of azov
crimea and i think there's increased
concern and of course today you saw that
the u.s ambassador is coming back to
washington for consultations
the u.s has been very clear about the
need to de-escalate
this situation and i think that the
in washington we're taking it uh taking
it very seriously right now
that this is the biggest military
buildup they have seen since 2014
and i think everybody including both in
washington
brussels on the european side is taking
it very seriously
what can u.s president biden do even
with his allies because at the end of
the day
you know ukraine is not a member of nato
that that's that's true and and the
president has said that that the u.s
nato will not get involved militarily
again
this is about diplomacy it's about
bringing
uh russia uh to the conclusion that
their actions
if they decide to take it in in ukraine
and against ukraine would be against its
interests
and so right now there's lots of
consultations back and forth
uh minister uh foreign affairs of
ukraine is correct that the us does have
tools in its tool belt
including sanctions it can accelerate
ukraine's nato membership
process as well further accelerating
euro-atlantic integration for ukraine
and bringing it closer
but so those are some of the things that
we're seeing right now we already saw
last week
with an introduction of new sanctions uh
focused on a number of items which you
mentioned at the beginning including
response u.s elections
response to concerns about head hunting
in
afghanistan's concerns about cyber cyber
wins as well
these are the things that i think that
that the administration is contemplating
right now
thinking about but i think what we want
to see right now in washington i think
elsewhere
is de-escalation and unfortunately
moscow and the kremlin is moving in the
wrong direction
well jonathan why should ukraine believe
president biden when he says that there
will be consequences if russia
moves against ukraine biden also said
that there would be consequences for
saudi arabia over the murder of
journalist
jamal khashoggi and the world is still
waiting for those consequences
yeah look the this administration uh
from day one
has said that it was going to hold
russia accountable uh for action
that it took place over the last several
years including uh i mentioned the cyber
intrusion but also the elections of
deference
afghanistan and so it actually has a
proven record
of introducing sanctions and responding
to actions taken by the kremlin now
we're not only talking about what's
taking place
uh on ukraine's borders but we're also
talking about what's taking place
internally in russia
as well and so i think there will be a
response from the
united states and from uh u.s partners
including in europe
to what's taking place and that has
happened before it happened even
post 2014 when action was taken in
crimea
and in the donbass where the u.s
responded with sanctions and really
led the effort to i think to push back
on kremlin actions then so i expect that
it will take place
in addition the u.s is already under
this administration
continue to provide uh weapons uh to
ukraine
and that's something that's important
it's not only the united states that's
doing that
but it's other nato partners in the
united states that are working to
support ukraine security
jonathan i'd like to talk about
alliances in a moment but first i want
us to listen in to what
german chancellor angela merkel said
today at a council of europe
video conference take a listen
i have the impression that with
nordstrom 2 we
may be waging a conflict that is much
wider
and touches upon the question of the
extent to which we want to trade with
russia
especially in the energy sector
germany has decided to build nordstrom 2
but it's a political battle that many
see differently
jonathan miracle in the past has
regarded nordstrom 2
as a matter of energy policy not a
matter of geopolitics
do you hear her beginning to shift her
stance there
i think there is a number of items that
that berlin is increasingly concerned
about one is clearly
the situation on the border with ukraine
where the chancellor has been clear
about the need to de-escalate and to
step back
but i also think the situation with uh
with leading opposition figure
uh navalny is also of deep concern to
germany
um the fact that right now he cannot get
the mental
medical attention that he needs uh he is
one of over several hundred political
prisoners
in russia right now so i think there's a
whole host of actions
that russia russia has taken that are of
deep concern
to the german government nordstrom 2 is
one of those issues that's been on the
table
between transatlantic allies it's
something that i know that the biden
administration
uh cares deeply about uh president biden
has said that he opposes
uh nordstrom two uh the u.s congress has
spoken loudly on this
uh and so there's a potential on both
sides
if any action is taken you can see a
shift a possible shift
in the german government and i expect
that the u.s will continue to push hard
on this issue
if germany were to halt nordstrom to
jonathan would that strengthen or weaken
the western alliance vis-a-vis russia
well i i think that you know the the
position has been out of concern about
energy security in europe and about
being reliant on
russia as an energy supplier a supplier
that in the past has cut off
uh energy resources when it suited its
needs
so i think from the perspective of the
u.s i think
absolutely the nordstrom 2 project not
going forward
is seen as something that's positive and
important for
for u.s and transatlantic security and
energy security
so absolutely you mentioned the kremlin
critic alexis navalny he
is in a hospital now after being
transferred from
his prison cell do you think western
pressure had anything to do with that
uh well first of all i have zero zero
confidence
that mr putin the kremlin will do the
right thing in terms of mr navalny's
health
i think there's many people here have
come to the conclusion that they would
like to see
that mr putin would like to see him dead
and so i think there's no confidence
here because
his doctors and others are not allowed
in and so right now we're relying on the
kremlin
which is locked locking up political
prisoners like mr navalny
uh for this type of support this is the
same government
that just several months ago tried to
poison and kill
the leading opposition figure so i think
that
it's really it's important for the us
and others to keep focus on this
all right jonathan katz with the german
marshall fund joining us tonight from
washington as always jonathan we
appreciate your time and your insights
thank you